[Applause]
our next speaker is Nicholas Rubin for
Google
um and he's going to tell us about
industrial applications of hamiltonian
simulation and Beyond the prospect of
nisk and fault tolerant algorithms so
welcome
all right uh thanks for having me here
uh it's uh kind of a rare I I work up
here in San Francisco even though most
of the Google Quantum AI team is down in
Santa Barbara and Los Angeles
um a part of the algorithms team and so
sort of our goal is to figure out what
to do with quantum computers and sort of
convince School Executives that it's a
good idea to continue to build one of
these and so I'm going to talk a little
bit about that in the context of
industrial applications so where
um specifically in sort of chemistry and
material simulation industry they use
hamiltonian simulation and sort of what
that accuracy bar is
and so I'm going to talk about a nisk
experiment that is really a
collaboration between myself and then
Bill Huggins and Tom O'Brien looking at
generalizations of purification
techniques and then also I'll talk about
sort of some false tolerant algorithms I
know this the topic of the conference is
not is not that but I do want to put
that out there just to kind of set the
bar for uh what industry applications
sort of look like and what are the scale
okay
so
yeah if you go and look at chemistry or
Material Science and Industry you get
problems about of this scale so I think
probably everyone has heard of the
famoco uh you know Active Space or
active site of this enzyme that fixes
nitrogen makes this big challenge
problem and at least in quantum
chemistry and it's been used as this
benchmarking Quantum information to kind
of Benchmark algorithms you can ask
things about drug Discovery I mean these
are sort of the normal things that if
you pick up you know the the newspaper
and you see someone talking about
Quantum Computing they say this is what
it's going to be used for
people talk about battery cathodes and
and some other catalysts and I just
wanted to kind of put out there that
like quantum chemistry has been
developing for the last 50 years and we
are quite good at simulating these
systems and so I sort of put whether
they're solved or not uh here at the
bottom this one maybe should be
semi-solved
um but yeah we can simulate and describe
these systems very very well so I want
to kind of touch on where Quantum
Computing sits in front of these uh in
these contexts
Okay so
um I've sort of been I I'm a Quantum
chemist by training uh I entered the
kind of quantum information field in
2016. uh and since then I've been sort
of keeping track of nisk experiments I
mean this is not an exhaustive list but
uh it's some of the bigger ones and uh
so starting from 2016 there's this two
qubit experiment there's the four qubit
and six qubit experiment from IBM and
then fast forwarding we have you know a
uh 12 qubit vqe experiment a 10 qubit VQ
experiment that I'm going to be talking
about and some larger simulations that
aren't actually in the vqe setting
um but this is sort of to Benchmark sort
of where we are in the field in terms of
nisk experiments
um and that these are all well within
the regime of what chemists would really
consider classically simulable and I
think this goes along exactly with the
previous talks in terms of where we are
okay so I want to kind of
rewind to 2019 I still think that this
is the largest vqe experiment that was
done uh sort of after the 2019 Supremacy
experiment uh Sergio sort of asked what
what you should do with a one of these
devices and of course in my Infinite
Wisdom I said you should run an infield
theory on this very expensive object but
it's actually really great because it's
a primitive for a lot of the other
circuits in fact these Givens rotation
circuits have a lot of similarity to the
Clifford loader circuits that were
actually discussed earlier
um and so there are a couple of really
nice things about this so for what we're
doing in this experiment is starting in
some basis and second quantization and
we're performing a quadratic hamiltonian
Evolution and that can be decomposed as
follows into these kind of two local
Gates these are all match gates for for
those of you who would like a complexity
characterization of this circuit this is
all efficiently simulable
um and so
there are some nice things about this uh
we can verify the results we get
gradient estimation for for effectively
free we measure the one RDM of this
system uh for free fermion circuits
they're completely characterized by
their covariance Matrix hence called
gaussian circuits uh they're The
covariance Matrix is effectively
expectation values of the second moments
associated with that and then we can use
purification and so what I mean by
purification here is that I can project
my one particle densy Matrix or my
covariance Matrix to a matrix that has
eigenvalues one or zero and so that's a
very powerful thing to do whenever
you're projecting and that completely
characterizes the circuit that I have
and we can look at the power of kind of
the standard error mitigation processes
starting from the sort of raw data up
here this is the energy error for a
particular model in fact it's the
hydrogen chain here
and we can see what happens when we just
have the raw data we can have post
selection purification helps a lot and
then vqe does do something and this is
there's a Fidelity witness for these
particular circuits that we can actually
back out a lower bound to the Fidelity
and so this looks quite good but we are
really relying on the power of this
purification this projection to a item
potent density Matrix
okay so
we want to take a step towards more
difficult simulations right to really
kind of see what is possible in the nisk
setting and so sort of my proposal for a
sort of intermediate step instead of
doing the entire fermionic simulation
problem what we can do is sort of stop
halfway and so in chemistry normally we
kind of partition up our Hilbert space
into sectors that correspond to
excitations from some particular Fermi
vacuum right so that in some in some
cases if you're in condensed matter this
might be the BCS state if you're a
Quantum chemist this is like a slighter
determinant the mean field state but
really we break up Hilbert space and
looking at the number of excitations out
of that
and so uh this is sort of a
characterization of that and the number
the number occupation space these are
the Slater determinants here
uh and if we force ourselves to work in
a space where all electrons compared uh
this is actually called the seniority
zero space
um and we can project our electronic
hamiltonian here describing the
electrons in any chemical system or
condensed matter system uh into a Fermi
into a spin model here and so what this
sort of says is that for every kind of
complicated looking two-body fermionic
model there is a spin model Heisenberg
spin model that sort of lives in a
Subspace of this and so that's sort of
the model that we're going to Target
simulating as this intermediate regime
between mean field Theory and an exact
simulation
yeah
okay so uh there's a couple of really
nice things about this classically so I
said before that we usually work in some
particular Fermi vacuum classically what
we can do is solve the couple cluster
equations this is a many body expansion
of the wave function where we do a
similarity transform of the hamiltonian
and then we just use Wix theorem to
evaluate all of those uh those Matrix
elements the bch expansion truncates at
order four because our hamiltonian only
has two body interactions and this is a
non-unitary transformation okay so
that's all actually a very efficient in
fact in this case it's uh cubic scaling
so again we have something that's close
to our experiment that we could possibly
verify our Quantum onsats is going to be
a unitary form of that and that's some
fabric of gates that we've sort of seen
before as a nice dense layer of of gates
in one dimension and this is a
composition of something that's free a
free fermion rotation so this is a
quadratic fermionic Hamilton followed by
a swap operation and so this lifts it
from the family of match Gates into
something that's eqp complete actually
so that's the kind of gate set that
we're going to work with so formally
this is not simulable efficiently but it
does have an analog that that is
efficient efficiently simulable of
course if we get rid of the swap then
this whole thing again is free fermions
okay so uh we what we wanted to do is
actually test two versions of a uh error
mitigation strategy that sort of
generalized this idea of purification
that we had in the hartree fog
experiment and so the two icos are
actually quite closely related uh one is
called virtual distillation the other is
a verified phase estimation or Echo
verification and they sort of work in a
similar way but they look at face value
quite different and so starting with
virtual distillation we know that if we
take a density Matrix and raise it to
some power right we're projecting the we
converge to the the highest eigenvector
of that state exponentially quickly I
mean this is the basis of lentos method
right and we know that if we can measure
our expectation values with respect to
that and then renormalize by this Trace
value then we can potentially get error
mitigated expectation values like for
example the energy of our system and so
this is called virtual distillation
because we're never actually explicitly
building this Matrix power here or this
density Matrix power what we're doing is
sort of simulating it in effect uh so
this is a well-known trick in Quantum
information you can use the uh the swap
operator here cyclic permutations on a
tensor product of your density matrices
to simulate uh this higher order row so
this has been used I believe Jordan
Cutler's the first use of this actually
maybe was getting cooler so doing a
virtual cooling of some thermal State
and that sort of inspired this this work
but you get circuits like this where you
run two copies for example if this n is
two you run two copies of your
experiment and you do this swap
operation and then you measure
so in a similar fashion we can where
we've doubled our space complexity here
we can actually do something quite
similar and unroll it in the time
Dimension and so this is the kind of
core of the verified phase estimation in
this case we have something that looks
quite like an echo verification circuit
we have our state preparation unitary
our observable and we want to unprepare
and then we want to project back on our
zero State and we know that at least up
to this Square our expectation values of
any of observables are the survival
probability of this particular circuit
and so uh you know with some
approximations about what the noise is
doing in these circuits at least in the
forward Direction and The Backwards
Direction uh we can say that as you
introduce noise it's effectively a
scalar on the Fidelity of your circuit
times this expectation value
so there's a couple things that we can
do in a similar fashion that we
estimated this kind of Purity
denominator we can estimate this
Fidelity by removing the observable uh
rescaling and then of course we can get
rid of the square by using a controlled
operation I mean this is effectively
what you're doing in a swap test this is
just a blocking coding with one qubit
right and so that's sort of the core of
verified phase estimation it's unrolling
in time what we're doing in Virtual
distillation sort of a morally similar
fashion
okay so what happens in this experiment
uh we have that unitary pair couple
cluster onsats and we had to do a couple
of things right in the virtual
distillation we need to have two copies
of this and then Swap and then the echo
verification we need to run this forward
and then backwards but with a observable
here in the middle and so the circle the
circuit that we use is actually on a
ring that way it makes our the
measurements of an all to all connected
Heisenberg Model A little bit easier
um
and it sort of starts like this where we
assign some initial uh Fermi vacuum here
uh this is the half filling state for
example uh and then we run this fabric
as I showed in the previous slide and
then we do these swaps at the end for
measurements
um again since we're working with qubits
now because in the scenes already
seniority zero space uh it's all or all
electrons are coming paired up and that
forms a su-2 algebra that we can just
map directly onto our Heisenberg model
so that's sort of how we get from
fermions to qubits and why these are
there's no like fermionic language in
this particular circuit representation
and so uh sort of in the same way that
the Givens rotation circuits are linear
depth we sort of do the densest possible
first order Trotter approximation of
that unitary where we have this Givens
rotation Fabric or given swap rotation
fabric these are not match Gates uh but
fully uh
uh Universal and so for the echo
verification case uh we needed to do
that control to get rid of that square
and so what we do is actually a
non-controlled version of this where we
create a superposition in the initial
State between a state where our unitary
Acts or our generator of Dynamics acts
as an identity and this initial Fermi
vacuum and so what that is is just a GHC
state right and so we produce a GHC
State we run our Dynamics we measure our
observable or we time evolve our
observable because uh we're trying to
get we're doing sort of a phase
estimation here and then we run this
back and we post select on zero okay so
those are the two schemes and that's
sort of what's happening in this
experiment
okay so uh
the system that we sort of looked at was
where there were two actually the first
one is this uh Richardson gaudon model
it's a model of a superconductor
um yeah it's you can think of this as
this is just the BCS hamiltonian uh
where uh this can be tuned right uh it's
nothing sort of fancy uh and if we look
at the performance of the device let's
just look at this top left box here uh
the V the raw vqe here is sort of up
here and this is quite a large energy
error we can post select right
effectively we can I'll post select on
zero and and
um for virtual distillation a number
operator and then applying the echo
verification and the virtual
distillation these are quite accurate
over the entire parameter regime this is
sort of a cute little model because we
know that pair couple cluster diverges
in this regime so it's we're not at we
would not be able to accurately simulate
the in this regime and we know that BCS
is sort of wrong in the other regime
here and so it's it's kind of a nice
little example where sort of are two
first classical approximations are not
going to get this right of course this
is a 10 site system you can easily
simulate this and there's lots of other
techniques that you could use to dial in
the classical side but in some sense
this is to demonstrate the two error
mitigation strategies uh that are sort
of this generalization of the
purification
um yeah so here are the sort of energy
errors that kind of similar to what we
were showing the first experiment uh
these are quite large
I think uh when you kind of compare that
to what is needed for chemical
simulation but uh maybe in this setting
where you're looking more at an order
parameter and this is the
superconducting gap order parameter you
don't need such tight accuracy
considerations and so this is sort of a
similar story if you pick your intervals
correctly you don't need as tight and
accuracy bound and so uh this is quite
nice Echo verification and verified
phase estimation perform kind of
similarly they provide an order of
magnitude improvement over the kind of
unmitigated vqe and this is quite a
robust protocol at least the circuit is
capturing the physics of the model
Emily we're getting this entire regime
here
okay and as of course as a chemist uh I
I don't want to publish paper without a
molecule in it really
um and so this one is a example of a
sort of kind of canonical reaction in
fact uh it's the canonical example of
Woodward Hoffman rules I got the Nobel
Prize in 1986 I believe
um and uh here what we're doing is we're
taking a cyclobutene which is a square
molecule and we're kind of what we're
doing is we're pulling it apart into a
diene
and so there's a particular pathway in
fact in molecular orbital Theory quantum
mechanics is explaining specifically how
this is going to ring open
um and so what we do is simulate that on
the device with this in the seniority
zero space to see if we can kind of
accurately model that entire pathway
so again this is in seniority zero the
kind of smaller system is six qubits the
uh 10 qubit one is right on top of it of
course going to a larger hamiltonian
here in terms of the Active Space isn't
kind of giving you a lot but we are
capturing Dynamic correlation between
namely the the part of the hamiltonian
that you would get by a perturbative
expansion of your wave function uh this
that's effectively the gap between this
red line which is mean field and this
and these blue curves and again this
story is sort of similar at small scales
error mitigation Works quite well but if
you want to scale this up to something
reasonable and demand the accuracies of
quantum of chemistry calculations these
are nowhere close so these green
points here
are all the 10 qubit Echo verification
data
so in terms of parallelity with this
curve that's pretty atrocious and the
error bars are very large because this
is a very shot hungry protocol
effectively as the Fidelity goes down
you're post selecting on zero this
becomes a more and more difficult thing
to do with statistical certainty
um uh the kind of
the movement of these as a function of
the reaction coordinate here sort of
also tells us that the device was
drifting quite a lot
okay so that sort of ends the story on
nisk
um didn't want to dwell too long on that
just because it is
I guess the takeaway is that it's quite
difficult even with fairly sophisticated
error mitigation that is doing a
projective or a projection namely
something that's purifying your state we
can we can kind of design protocols that
are doing that it's still quite
expensive to do chemistry simulations at
a quantitative level
and so the
um
you know
what exactly would you mock you with
store here and what changes that you
have more people so so I'm assuming that
you need more cubits you want to do
something
interesting but but how does that you
know how precisely does that translate
amazing
or is it just doing the same molecule
with understanding it better
yeah that's a that's a good question I
sort of breezed over some of that
um so like normally when you simulate a
molecule the hamiltonian is defined as
some content you know the the
differential operators is partial
differential equation it's continuous
right and so the first thing we do is
pick a basis to discretize right and so
in some sense that's setting the end the
scale the number of qubits of your
system right and then there's a question
of
given a mean field guess right uh the
degree at which
you need different Slater determinants
to describe the full system
so for example if you have a hybrid
model or spin liquid or something like
that you might need a lot of
determinants to describe this but for a
lot of like molecular systems even if
they're very very large they can be
treated very very well with perturbation
Theory and that's sort of what I meant
on the first slide some of those
catalysts they they look like big
molecules you can imagine like 10 cubits
per atom on that slide right but some of
those of course are soft because couple
cluster and perturbative expansions work
very very well
so that's sort of the setting it's hard
to tell a priori
and so you can effectively generate a
hamiltonian that's just the interactions
around your Fermi surface
and then that can set that's for example
what we're doing here we just say okay
there's some number of occupied orbitals
in this small little molecule let me
just pick three above and three below
the Fermi surface I'm going to use that
to Define my seniority zero and you can
do that with much more complicated uh
systems I'll describe one at the end but
it is an art to do that correctly
because there the basis set matters uh
set kind of the one particle
rotation that you choose matters like
all that stuff kind of goes in and
that's sort of where the chemistry bit
comes comes back into the problem of
simulation
yeah it's quite hard to give like formal
results on this
okay
but in an effort to give formal results
uh I'm going to talk a little bit now
about sort of progress towards
simulating something of Industry
relevance uh with fall tolerance so we
saw on the nisk side that uh it's quite
difficult to reach something that is
very accurate that my ex my colleagues
in Industry at chemical companies uh
would say okay that's a useful
calculation for me to run but what about
in Fall tolerance so Google has a
timeline for building this device and
we'd like to know sort of how big it
needs to be and what we're going to be
able to solve sort of about the end of
the decade when we when we build it okay
so there's been a lot of progress uh
this table
is certainly not everything but it is a
kind of
compendium of the progress that has been
made at least in Phase estimation so I
think Lynn was here yesterday talking
about ground state preparation but this
is this is sort of a different form uh
this is just saying let's define my
system and how expensive is it going to
be to do phase estimation not worrying
so much about the state preparation bit
okay and so starting in 2005 with a lawn
when he was I believe here at Berkeley
uh you know there's of course it's known
that in second quantization this is
going to scale linearly in the system
size n and there's going to be some
polynomial dependence on the number of
gates right and that was unknown but
then if you fast forward over the years
you know we have some fairly terrible
scaling down to now something that's
actually linear in the basis size up to
this new parameter Lambda here and still
linear in the space complexity of my
problem
and so given this sort of improvement
one of the activities of our group is to
sort of characterize well what are the
constant factors associated with these
algorithms and so this is a fairly
tedious process compiling for a computer
that doesn't exist yet but it can be fun
uh just to see uh sort of how long these
algorithms are going to take to run
outside of a big O sort of reasoning
um so it's time for an honest assessment
of what's going on here and so uh here
are some of the systems from the first
slide that I showed we have our famoco
Catalyst many of you have seen this and
then in this PRX particularly uh it was
calculated given a particular
hamiltonian decomposition it would take
about 4 million physical qubits and four
days of runtime for one eigenvalue
estimation of course to solve the famoco
problem we would need many there's a
question what's the assumption
uh this is
oh yeah so we're compiling this down to
the surface code and we fix an error
rate that is below threshold but not too
far and then we make some assumptions
about the number of T factories we have
the cycle time of the service code I'll
talk a little bit about that but in some
sense those are sort of details and you
sort of just figure out exactly how fast
things are going to be produced in our
case it's going to be specifically how
fast tofflies are produced
um but again so this is this p450 drug
Target effectively uh this particular
actors this enzyme that where this
active site lives uh metabolizes about
50 of the drugs that are on the market
so when you design a drug you actually
don't want it to bind too strongly to
this because then uh if it does you
metabolize it and it's no longer
effective again similar sort of scenario
you could probably guess from the
relative size and this to your question
to imagine is is sort of where we had to
be very careful selecting an active
space for example here's an iron right
in the center of this and here's this
carbon uh sort of ring outside of it you
might sort of expect that the iron is
really where all the action is happening
and you wouldn't need to treat all of
these at a very high level of quantum
mechanical Theory and so that's sort of
what we do though to describe everything
properly here you do need a pretty big
Active Space
um and then the other one is materials
this is definitely more recent work from
earlier this year we took a real battery
cathode material these are with our
colleagues at BASF and we cost out
exactly how long it's going to take to
simulate with some new method
development here
okay so uh sort of what does that look
like this is sort of the
kind of the mechanics of what we do uh
first how do we simulate something
within air correction for quantum
chemistry well we can prepare some wave
function with a reasonable overlap
namely it's not too small with respect
to the ground state uh we form some
circuit that's a propagator of a
function of our hamiltonian the kind of
canonical examples this function is the
identity function right just gives you
your hamiltonian back and that means
then our unitary would be at some type
of Trotter right but there's other
functions that we can choose
then of course application of this
unitary we know if we do this in a
controlled way a phase Kickback this is
kind of basic Quantum information you
can induce a phase on this eigenstate
expansion of your initial state right
and then we know from phase estimation
that with probability that is
proportional to our initial overlap and
with error Epsilon we need 1 over
Epsilon or queries to the U that is that
we're going to build and so the goal
then is to say exactly how expensive is
that you to build
okay so the modern forms of this of
course are are cubanization our
kubernization forms are really just
looking at this particular Block
encodings in this case what that means
is that our function of our hamiltonian
is actually this weird function the ARP
cosine of our hamiltonian divided by
this parameter Lambda
since we're dividing our hamiltonian by
some parameter Lambda of course that
scales our phase estimation complexity
here if we want the same accuracy
okay so there's a lot of theory about
what what this can be and I can talk
about that at length later but I just
wanted to kind of just very quickly put
up like this is the protocol that we're
using and costing out namely we have an
estimate for how many queries to this U
that we need to call and then we cost
that specifically how expensive is it
going to be to build that U
okay so what are the space-time
considerations when we when we talk
about costing out Quantum algorithms uh
so we're going to build the device that
sort of looks like this it's about the
size of a school bus
these are all the control electronics
that qubits live in here
um it's a quasi-1d architecture
um and uh to the question earlier about
the what we compile into we make an
assumption about the surface code and we
make an assumption that there's some
particular physical qubit overhead for
uh to implement a logical qubit
and that we need to sort of pay
attention to do two different types of
gate sets or two one particular gate set
but two different types of operations
one would be toeflies or t Gates these
are quite slow in comparison to the
other set which are Cliffords and so
there's really a huge constant Factor
slowdown and so if you're from the
classical world you kind of treat uh
your Gates so like and anores to be the
same complexity or end of zores or nands
and zores let's say to me the same
complexity but in this case uh one of
those takes many orders of magnitude uh
longer and so kind of the classical
version would be this nand gate this
takes a kind of space-time volume of a
transistor nanosecond right
um and then a Quantum nand gate or a
tofflal gate of course this is as a
space-time volume if you sort of write
down the entire distillation sequence
about tens of cubic seconds and so it's
certainly we really care about these
constant factors especially with
compiling to the number of toefli states
that we need and so that's going to be
the target
okay so uh very quickly I know not
everyone is probably familiar with with
uh kind of fault on algorithms and block
and blocking codings but I just wanted
to put this up uh to build that Arc
cosine we use a linear combination of
unitaries framework and effectively
there's two Primitives that we cost out
there's the select primitive which is
effectively as a for Loop right select
is taking some register index L our
state and applying the Ulf uh unitary so
we're representing our hamiltonian as a
linear combination of unitaries there's
some weight and there's a unitary right
um so that's a that's just a for Loop
and we know how to write down a for loop
on a quantum computer in fact we put the
for loop on a binary tree then we
iterate over that with a depth first
search so that's exactly how it works
and then prepare is building a
particular superposition uh we can do
some something kind of similar uh and
then uh you can find many lecture notes
on particular on the particulars of what
lcus are doing uh but in some sense uh
you can view it as a block encoding
namely this unitary is putting the
hamiltonian up here in this upper left
block and we apply the hamiltonian to
our state of course selecting on the
insula qubit being like zero for example
this is just one additional in silicubit
assuming or hamiltonian has Norm less
than spectral spectral Norm less than
one
okay so if that didn't make any sense
that's fine I'll get back to the
chemistry stuff now
um okay so we have these two Primitives
that we're going to cost out to build
that R cosine function right and we have
our hamiltonian that looks something
like this right this is now the full
hamiltonian not projected to the
seniority zero space or anything like
that and our goal is to represent it as
a linear combination of unitaries and
that statement is pretty General you can
pick any set of unitaries here that you
have an efficient implementation for and
in fact that's sort of where the
chemistry part comes back in there's
different particular factorizations of
this four tensor which is the coulomb
operator right
um there's two that sort of there's no
factorization case this is in some
tensor Network representation of that
four tensor we have a SVD or hoskey
decomposition depending on your flavor
of language and then we have two types
of hyper-contracted forms of this tensor
Network all these have different costs
in terms of implementations and this
goes back to on that first slide of the
phase of the kind of phase estimation
section I was talking about here there
was all those different complexities
those complexities were to come from the
types of tensor factorization that you
do so those are repeated down here for
you if you'd like to know specifically
like where some of these complexities
come from why is this one linear for
example how does Lambda scale with n
system size come talk to me later
but the nice thing is that with some of
the more sophisticated hyper-contracted
factorizations we can get sub mean field
scaling for uh performing a phase
estimation on on the some of these
systems and so that's pretty cool we can
go to very large system sizes
okay so uh I sort of mentioned in the
first slide some of these are solved and
some of these are not but again the goal
was to sort of characterize if we had a
large quantum computer would we be able
to solve some of these interesting
problems uh and so in that case we need
to set up a competition between
classical and the quantum case so this
is quite difficult it requires
assumptions about compiling into the
surface code
but we have a pretty good idea of what
is possible from an engineering
perspective and we also know what's
possible from a classical perspective in
this case we're picking an active space
this Active Space is defined by picking
this Center iron and then sort of
expanding the view of the number of Q of
the number of orbitals namely the number
of qubits that were involved in this
particular hamiltonian
uh you'd expect if you kind of go out
the action is sort of here at the center
and the orbitals become less important
as you expand
and we can compare exact diagonalization
this is full CI here dmrg with various
Bond Dimensions two are estimates of the
quantum runtime using the best best
methods that we have so this is pretty
cool because we do get to see a
crossover at least an estimated
crossover again this is compiling to a
device that isn't built yet and so these
are of course estimates but we do our
best to have these as upper bounds so
it's very likely that um
this is a little bit higher than than we
need than we need but there's new tools
that we're developing for example
software Frameworks that let us express
these algorithms that we can see exactly
how bad our upper bounds uh really are
and so we guess that around 80 qubits
that's like right around here in terms
of orbitals
um that we'd see some type of crossover
um in terms of simulation time
so this is pretty reasonable in terms of
actual wall time of course dmrg is close
to embarrassingly parallel and so you
can sort of bring this down what we did
is make a comparison here as Fair as
possible namely setting the number of
CPU threads to the number of top League
factories that are T factories that you
have of course you can scale down this
complexity by adding more T factories
and you can scale down this by adding
more CPUs and so there's a little bit of
an R to convincing people that this is a
reasonable thing to do but this also
just gives a sort of a general idea of
what the first class of quantum
computers that you know can do these
calculations are going to look like in
terms of uh the types of simulations
they can do
okay so I'm going to wrap up uh with
this part uh here soon uh I just wanted
to point out that we can do this on on
materials I showed this earlier uh
really the kind of cool thing about this
work is that we took a an actual
question in Industry they want to
simulate these lithium nickel oxide
systems there's a the ground state of
these systems is actually there's a
chemical question namely this should
yanteler distort based on band Structure
Theory but from x-ray it does not look
like it does and so this is a great
example of something where an electronic
structure calculation can at least help
experimentalists interpret why that is
happening and so naturally as compilers
we wanted to know exactly how long that
was going to take in order to do this we
had to introduce quite a bit new Theory
we had to symmetry adapt all of The
Blocking core block encoding oracles
that's select and prepare to include a
billion symmetries effectively with this
is K Point sampling on a quantum
computer
again we get a quad here in this case we
get a quadratic Improvement to
unsymmetry adapted but the costs for a
system like this are quite high and so
sort of the conclusion is a little bit
negative in this case if you want to
simulate at extremely high accuracy
these particular models it's going to be
quite expensive without some some new
Innovations in photon algorithms and so
I think it's important to cost these out
because we can actually stop just kind
of leaning into the hype saying of
course quantum computer will help with
this type of calculation in this case it
does not
okay and so I'll end there I think with
plenty of time uh
so I guess the takeaways I I hope
everyone everyone got from this there's
kind of sort of two parts that if we
just look at vqe and variational
algorithms of that flavor it's very very
difficult to get to the accuracies where
chemists would really pay attention
um
everything that we showed there is quite
has a lot of error we weren't able to
produce the correct curves though for
some different types of problems like
order parameters and superconducting
models there's definitely requires
slightly less precision and so we can we
can sort of get the right answers there
but even with fairly sophisticated error
mitigation where we're doing these
purifications effective effectively
purifying the entire density Matrix
because we're taking powers of the
density
we still it's quite challenging to get
good expectation values
and then of course uh in The Fault
tolerance setting there is actually a
lot of Hope if you take some of these
algorithms and cost out specifically how
expensive they are there is a regime
that these will be pretty useful
calculations for a lot of practitioners
uh in in quantum chemistry and Material
Science and so I think there is
certainly hope and it is exciting as we
kind of push forward in that area as
well
so thanks for listening
[Applause]
all right
foreign
great talk so uh following on umesh's
question now if I understood what you
said at the end there you get a
crossover uh at like 80 logical qubits
uh so then the question I have is
um
if I were in Industry designing
batteries what how many logical qubits
would I actually need to be useful is 80
above or below that number I mean I I
still haven't quite gotten that from
from your answers earlier I mean how
many do they actually need to be useful
so I think this this particular model is
is a bit special uh
we do see a sort of Brute Force
uh
like if you're to try to simulate this
Active Space at around 80 qubits right
this model a model of this particular
molecule because again we're projecting
down the size of that and that
hamiltonian to just an active set of of
uh orbitals
around 40 orbital description is pretty
challenging
um to do just from a sort of dmrg
perspective there is enough correlation
but I will say that as you increase the
size of the actor space namely going
from like 5 to 40 and you look at the
electrons
that are involved it's the same as three
electrons and there's a very chemical
reason for this there's an experiment
that says that this compound one should
be in a doublet State and there's only
so many ways that you can spin couple
things that are spin half to form a
doublet
and there's only so many electrons in
this case that you can borrow from and
so the answer is going to be one
electron three electrons five electrons
seven electron you know odd numbers all
the way up and so
since there's only the iron
participating this is sort of the
chemistry intuition coming in it's very
unlikely that there's more than three to
five
in fact I personally believe there's
three the reason this is actually
difficult is this particulars of the
energetics of this reaction namely this
entire pathway are very much dictated by
what's called Dynamic correlation the
things that you would treat at
perturbation Theory and actually doing
that is actually much more expensive
than these dmrg calculations and the
kind of the energy levels of different
spin States move around quite a lot and
so part of the reason you have to grow
to a large size here is actually to
balance the contribution between those
two
energies to your total to your answer
namely what's the ordering of the spin
States
in the
materials section these unit cells have
hundreds of electrons and so I didn't
explicitly put there you can see sort of
down here even to describe the system
this is thousands of orbitals and that's
partially because anytime you're
simulating a material you have to it's
automatically harder because you're
trying to converge it to the
thermodynamic limit and so the number of
qubits required in these cases is fairly
astronomical and that's partially
because of the methods that we use but
also just because these are huge
hamiltonians the only level of theory
that we could do here is effectively
auxiliary field Monte Carlo and
perturbation Theory it's extremely
difficult
of course even describing the
hamiltonians the two electron integrals
there are gigabytes and so you have to
get all of that information into your
circuit
and so there's that's where all the
compression techniques really start to
to matter and so I don't have like a
strict answer for how many qubits you
would need in this case just because
it's extremely difficult to say
certainly more than 80
um if you want to do this abbin issue if
you want to build a model hamiltonian
then it could be much smaller
hmm
that's why we must turn to embedding
theories in some way
[Applause]